en une année la reine d'une ruche est
capable de pondre près 2 400 milles eu
un nombre élevé mais nécessaire car une
abeille ouvrière ne vit que 30 à 45
jours à france miniature des animations
avec des apiculteurs sont proposés pour
en apprendre plus sur ces pollinisateurs
pourquoi les abeilles cette petite
histoire elle remonte à 2015
quand une habitante d'el en cours nous a
sollicités en nous expliquant qu'elle
souhaitait se lancer dans l'apiculture
nous a sollicités pour les installer à
france miniature
on a accepté le projet parce qu'on avait
également nous envie de s'inscrire dans
un projet de protection de
l'environnement
mieux découvrir tout cet environnement
là le monde des abeilles des ruches de
l'apiculture et de le faire découvrir à
nos visiteurs
atelier collage réalisation de bougies
en cire d'abeille et chasse aux insectes
les enfants peu habitué à ce type
d'exercice ont surmonté leur peur pour
attraper une abeille et pour l'étudier
la capelle sont sauvages ils et elles
sont aujourd'hui jaune la regarda
s'étaient mis d'accord au début on a
quelque chose on a capturé des abeilles
pouvoir leur race et tous mes calculs et
des abeilles on a découvert comment
elles naissent et comment
elles se développent et on a aussi vu
des abeilles
de toutes les différences une découverte
de ces insectes indispensable à notre
alimentation
les apprentis apiculteurs sont attendus
tous les mercredis après midi du mois de
juillet